welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's moon night follows
stephen grant a guy suffering from
dissociative identity disorder without
even realizing it chalking it up to
sleepwalking and a real complicated
method of flirting i'm at the restaurant
mistake it's steak time
yeah i ate steak by myself thanks two
days ago
nice game bro she gets her steak time
and then you get your mistake time what
day is it today
sunday sir no
see
really the first episode confirms that
steven's dreams are not fantasies but
really his alternate identity marks
spectre taking control of his body and
taking him to strange dangerous
situations yet all of it real but how
real is it because moon knight both the
source material and the series it looks
like is carefully designed to leave us
in a state of uncertainty over basic
reality that everything presented
through the eyes of this unreliable
narrator not just the more obvious
ghosts and visions but even simple words
printed on paper might be an illusion
i'm gonna break down all the weird
little glitches you might have missed to
explain how i don't think we can really
trust anything we're seeing right now by
the way the best way to support our
channel is to get our new moon knight
inspired tomb of the moon god shirt part
of our limited edition latest obsession
live which gives you the added option to
write in a custom shout out for our moon
night after shows get that over at
newrockstarsmerch.com so while promoting
the series layla actress mae calamali
pitched it as the tone is like fight
club meets indiana jones well the
indiana jones parallels with the
mysterious golden relics pointing the
way to the ancient world are clear but
fight club is famously a story of an
unreliable narrator unaware that his
best friend tyler durden is actually
himself a twist hinted at throughout the
movie by subtle visual clues that didn't
venture hid in the imagery similarly i
think if you re-watch moon night episode
1 closely so much of stephen grant's
journey even when you discount the
obvious fantastical leaps and lapses the
episode calls attention to so many
little things that you overlook and take
for granted grant
these things do not add up or make
logical sense it's actually possible
that much of if not all of this man's
waking life as steven grant is a waking
fantasy actually in a recent press
conference ethan hawk even confirmed
this saying the director muhammad was
really embracing steven's mental illness
as a way to create an unreliable
narrator and once you've broken the
prism of reality everything that the
audience has seen is from a skewed point
of view and that's really interesting
for the villain because am i even being
seen as i am and by the way thanks to
marvel for inviting us to listen in on
that junket so every morning stephen
talks to his mother on the phone a
mother who probably doesn't exist he
thanks her for sending him postcards
leaving us wondering who is sending
these postcards perhaps it's the mark
identity sending the postcards to keep
steven in the cycle either way steven is
used to living an incomplete delusional
life he teaches a little girl in the
museum about the egyptian burial rituals
and only the worthiest would be allowed
to pass through the field of reeds and
did it suck for you getting rejected
from the field of reads what if that
makes sense because i'm not dead am i
stevie
yeah that second little mi which oscar
isaac discreetly slips in tells us that
even steven is questioning his reality
not sure whether he is alive or dead
that even this simple moment in the
museum could be the fantasy of a dying
man or a deceased soul trapped in an
underworld now steven repeatedly points
out historical inaccuracies with the
merch they sell in the gift shop i don't
even know what this has to do with egypt
really so they didn't have that
background did they no
they're like figs and dates and then
later while doing inventory with donna
the anyad
you know like the super group of
egyptian gods you know you've got horus
osiris tef nut shoes
but there's been a major blunder because
they've got seven gods here and the
onion has nine now as i pointed out in
the breakdown stephen is correct that
the iliad of egyptian mythology has nine
members they are the sun god atom shu
and tefnut deities of air and moisture
geb and nut gods of the earth in the sky
and their children osiris isis set and
nephthys that is nine then not often but
in some interpretation some historians
will include in the indiana tenth member
the son of osiris horus but horus would
make it ten however steven mentions
horus first in his listing which is just
odd like anyone who was fact-checking
someone on the nine members of the iniad
would not mention horus first also this
poster clearly shows the name of the
egyptian deity hathor who is not part of
the idiot now hathor is a very important
deity to mythology the consort to horus
the sun god raw representation of
femininity but is just not considered
part of the any ad per se now throughout
the episode various shots of steven show
him through reflected surfaces mirrors
puddles on the ground but there's one
shot in the park at night time after
leaving his street performer buddy where
we see steven thinking we're seeing him
in real life but when a leaf lands on
the puddle it reveals what we thought
was real to be an illusion a reflection
of real life perhaps gluing us in to
everything we think being real is
actually fake later on we see a textbook
on screen in close-up showing what we
think is the lineage of the gods of the
innie ad but the listed order is just
all mixed up osiris is listed at the top
then his son horus is listed beneath him
and then beneath horus is adam which
would definitely not be the case and
then also again hawthor is listed there
on the inadd page despite not being a
member of the indie ad now maybe this
lineage is not depicting the exact
members of the inead and maybe this is a
historical interpretation of egyptian
mythology that i'm not aware of but
overall stephen's um actually strikes me
as the kind of thing that in our society
especially on social media nowadays a
lot of self-described buffs on various
subjects like i will admit i have done
this in the past during various casual
trivia nights some folks might know a
bit about a subject maybe they took a
college class in it or they watched a
youtube video on the subject and then
afterwards they will go around
confidently correcting others as if they
are an expert with a degree in the
subject despite when you actually look
it up they are objectively wrong on the
facts so are we looking at production
design mistakes made by the prop
designers perhaps and in my experience
doing these kind of breakdowns these
kind of inconsistencies when they come
up are best attributed to incompetence
rather than conspiracy but we also know
that this series was carefully
researched in the special thanks they
credit egyptology consultant ramy romani
a documentarian and expert in egyptian
history with a ton of credits to his
name this is the guy so if these are
mistakes i think they're intentional i
think they're berenstain glitches in the
eyes of an unreliable narrator who in
his self-perception fantasy is an
underappreciated expert in egyptology
but in reality like most average folks
he's got some of his facts mixed up so
later when stephen returns from the alps
he begins to catch on to the glitches in
his life his goldfish gus now has
regrown his spin mysteriously obviously
replaced the past few days and steven's
been out and he realized that time has
left forward a few days and of course he
starts perceiving his alter-ego mark and
the ghostly deity of konchu but then we
get this crazy scene in the elevator
obviously seeing ghosts mark's
perception is very much being distorted
by the haunted nature of this scene but
specifically the way the elevator moves
makes no sense steven hits the button
for the ground floor repeatedly we see
that and then the lift descends stopping
on the third floor despite no one
summoning it okay but then it goes down
to the second floor where presumably it
was summoned by that old woman whom
stephen saw as concho but if that woman
was at the far end of the hallway she
could not have summoned the elevator and
then at this point the elevator should
have still been headed down to the
ground the way if you're at the top
floor of the building hit the button for
the ground floor and if people join you
on other floors on the way down it still
goes all the way down even if someone
accidentally gets on who's trying to go
up but instead this elevator for no
reason goes back up to the fifth floor
now sure steven and this woman do
comment that this building has some
faulty wiring but either way this is a
magic elevator that follows the rules of
steven's nightmare not the rules of
reality so then after this conscious
jump scare stephen wakes up on a city
bus he exits this bus but then he turns
around to see arthur harrow back on that
bus right near where stephen was
previously standing so what was going on
on this bus before stephen woke up if
harrow was stalking steven why didn't he
approach him when they were both a few
feet away from each other on that bus
and then at the end of the episode when
the jackal chases stephen through the
museum as the jackal touches the
museum's surfaces that are seen in the
main hall it leaves no visible scratches
or marks at all now sure in the back
rooms plenty of stuff gets knocked
around it kicks the door open it
unhinges some of the light panels when
the thing actually tears open the
bathroom door we don't see it happen we
only hear it from steven's perspective
as he transitions into moon knight
obviously we know this jackal is a cgi
character who isn't really interacting
with the space anyway and i pointed out
in the breakdown how in the profile shot
of steven's transformation the mummy
wrappings are not reflected covering his
neck and shoulders in the mirror his
clothes blow back but we don't see the
wrappings themselves in that mirror shot
until we cut to the wide shot i'm to say
that there is enough in this episode to
suggest a lot of this could be in
steven's mind and i present all of this
evidence to you to make up your own mind
as you watch this series and as you
watch do so with a skeptical eye because
by the end of this we may all be kicking
ourselves saying that the whole time
biggie was right it was all a dream
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you